-Guys, today is Friday,
and that's usually
when I catch up
on some personal stuff.
I check my in-box,
return some e-mails,
and, of course,
I send out thank-you notes.
And I was running a bit behind.
Is that okay?
Can I write out
some thank-you notes now?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I appreciate that.
James, can I get some
thank-you-note-writing music,
please?
[ Soft music playing ]
Thank you, Ohio, for legalizing
recreational weed.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wait. You're telling me
a state known for eating chili
on top of spaghetti just now
legalized weed?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on.
-Ohio!
[ Soft music playing ]
-Thank you,
"The Golden Bachelor's"
"Women Tell All" episode,
for starting with a warning
that the show may be disturbing
to viewers under 65.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Soft music playing ]
Thank you, Election Day,
for forcing all of us
to make exceptionally
important decisions
in our old high-school
gymnasium.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Soft music playing ]
Thank you,
apartment smoke detector,
for alerting me
there's a fire by doing
a Mariah Carey impression.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Soft music playing ]
Thank you, autocorrect,
for waiting
until the exact second I hit
"send" to ruin a message.
I mean, come on. What?
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Soft music playing ]
Thank you, Pizza Hut
Hong Kong's new Snake Pizza,
for being the first time
a delivery guy says,
"Who ordered the snake pizza?",
and it's not the start
of a porno.
You guys, we --
There you have it.
Those are our thank-you notes.
We'll be right back with
Tom Hiddleston, everybody.